[Music]
are these golf balls
a science fiction set
an alien invasion
nope
this is balvagon
and the only inhabitants here are humans
[Music]
located in the netherlands about an hour
away from amsterdam are 50 sphere houses
made from cement and reinforced with
fiberglass
volvo oregon which absolutely translates
to ball or bulb homes was built in 1984
by the dutch artist and sculptor darice
kreshkam
it was created and supported by a
subsidy from the dutch government for
experimental housing projects
inside the houses are three levels
bedrooms on the ground bathroom on the
middle and a living space on the top
although these homes look out of this
world their intention was to bring its
inhabitants closer to nature
the round windows allow views of the
outside environment from almost any
angle and the complex itself is
positioned near a scenic canal
the designer passed away in 2014 however
his legacy lives on as these homes are
still lived in today
[Music]
jetliners are basically flying homes
it's a sealed pressure canister it's
incredibly strong
it will last practically forever
[Music]
i'm bruce campbell and you're inside the
cockpit area of my 727 home
[Music]
i can appreciate that some folks might
feel a bit isolated or that it might
simply strike them as an unusual living
environment but for me it's always felt
completely natural
my entry is via the aft air stairs which
are retractable and are retracted
whenever i leave for an extended time
the aft area of the aircraft now is my
living space
my very primitive shower is located
there
the two natural aft laboratories are
both functional
sleeping quarters are there in the form
of a simple futon sofa and bench where i
spend lots of time embellishing elements
of the aircraft
jetliners retire at the rate of about
three per day
for the most part i think we shred them
and then we spin around 180 degrees and
make a home after having just shredded
an aerospace class home sized structure
if you were an extraterrestrial looking
down on this behavior you'd wonder
whether this species has all its marbles
in place or
[Music]
not people have asked me whether it
crashed here and i simply restored the
wreck
that's an odd thing to hear it's it's
completely impractical
next time you're in a jetliner close
your eyes for a moment in your mind
remove all the seats and all the other
people
and then open your eyes with that vision
and consider the the expanse of the
living room
it's a good environment it really is
[Music]
b
[Music]
for somebody driving into town the first
time you wouldn't think there was a lot
here because
95 of it is hiding underground
people drive in and go
where is the place i don't understand
kuberpedi is from the aboriginal
pity which means white man in a hole
[Music]
at the moment upstairs it is about
122 degrees fahrenheit down here we're
sitting on about 71 72 degrees no air
conditioner necessary we're right out in
the middle of nowhere it takes a day to
drive here from adelaide i'd say there's
about
a thousand underground dwellings and
at least 1500 people living underground
we've got five underground churches
we've got underground motels there's
some amazing underground homes here many
bedrooms underground workshop you name
it underground we've pretty well got it
[Music]
i bought my dugout as a
fairly small two-bedroom dugout and i've
been extending it over the years some of
this i blasted out
when i could get away with it the cops
don't like us blasting in town we don't
do it anymore back in the old days if
somebody was going to have a baby we'd
rock around there with a couple of
compressors on a weekend and some
jackhammers and a couple of cartons of
beer and by the sunday night we dug out
a room cemented the floor and wired it
up and uh there's your new babies room
honey
even though we're so far away
geographically from anywhere else
i don't know why but we just love the
place to bits
[Music]
a nest is a place where you have a sense
of protection and strength
it's like an earth temple or a nature
temple
the wood is following a pattern but not
one branch is the same
as a nest builder i'm following those
patterns
most of the work is trying to bring out
the best of those shapes with each other
i'm jason fan and i'm a nest builder
i started building nests as a child the
nest building was really
an intuitive process of just
gathering branches and and building
forts originally and the nest grew and
got bigger
and more elaborate
now some of the nests are as big as a
hundred thousand pounds of wood
the hardest part of building the nest is
really gathering all of the wood
i use a chainsaw to cut wood i use a
machete to
cut off all the excess leaves and from
there i really assess you know what kind
of shapes i have what kind of material i
have to work with
the construction process of the nest
first is creating the foundation and the
infrastructure
and then i follow those larger
sculptural shapes that i bolt together
with smaller material that i can weave
in and around
i use every part of the tree the trunk
of the tree all the way down to the very
smallest twig and branch of the tree
i've gotten to where i'm used to
building them on flatbed trailers and
moving them around and in many cases i'm
transporting them across the country
because the nests are quite heavy i use
cranes and forklifts and different kinds
of equipment
this is all eucalyptus there's over
75 different species of eucalyptus on
this property i've built around 50 nests
all over the country and now primarily i
build the nests with kids
within an educational setting
as an educator like it's really
important to
work with kids and help them
realize that they have the ability to
shape and create an environment i'm
going to show you how we can integrate
those branches into the spiral
i love
getting kids out into nature interacting
with nature and and the nest is actually
very much a collaboration with nature
i know i've done a good job when it
looks like the nest is something that
could almost have grown out of the
ground
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people call this the dr seuss
house first of all nobody asked dr seuss
for permission to do that
they refer to that because of some of
the
ideas that dr seuss said
i think he was a genius and i think he
did a lot of good for the world
i try and write poetry and i kind of
think of this as a poem to the sky
[Music]
i am philip paul widener i'm the owner
and builder of goose creek tower i went
to mit and i'm kind of a frustrated
architect so i like building
i just designed it out of my head we
didn't have blueprints we drew it out on
cardboard plywood just as we were going
what i'm going to end up doing
eventually is put some hooks there and
hang pots and pans off them because this
is the kitchen i started to build a 40
by 40 scribe log cabin and i realized i
could put pillars on top and put another
house on top of a house
and i just kept going we got to 185 feet
and we stopped because um 200 feet is
federal air space
now i just have to finish it out
this is pretty much the last real stairs
there are multiple levels in there and
i've tried to count them and it's just
impossible it depends how you count
stories
i wanted to be able to see
and that's the reason i went up you can
actually see for
at least 300 miles and of course
when the northern lights are out
you can really see
i hope that goose creek tower will
inspire other people to do worthwhile
things not just in building but whatever
they do with their life
and every time i go up there it's a
different experience
kind of gives you a sense of the
enormity of the universe
[Music]